qu'est ce que la bolivie c'est un pays
dont la plus grande ville la base est à
4000 mètres d'altitude c'est le pays des
mines d'étain des incas du pétrole de la
jungle c'est aussi celui d'une
population d'environ 5 millions
d'habitants dont 70% ne participent pas
à la vie économique ce sont les indiens
et les paysans le petit prolétariat qui
se contentent de subsister c'est pour
eux que le che avait entrepris sa lutte
le régime précédent la fit assassiner et
à emprisonner régis debray un avion
militaire nous a déposés à camiri à midi
le jour de noël dans une chaleur
tropicale cameri c'est tout à l'extrême
sud de la bolivie près de l'équateur
c'est là que che guevara a été exécuté
c'est là que régis debray a été arrêté
le 19 avril 1967 alors qu'il quittait
précisément le maquis de che guevara
c'est là qu'a eu lieu son procès en
novembre 1967 c'est là qu'il a été
condamné à 30 ans de prison c'est là
qu'il passe ses journées
comment se passe aujourd'hui ici
écoutez c'est pas ici qu'elle se passe
dans votre en pis
ça dans ma cellule et la voix mais bien
le se passe dans une pièce qui petit
site qui à deux mètres sur trois
et où il ne se passait rien par
définition puisque monsieur je vous
demandais ce que c'est et physiquement
très dure non je crois que vraiment
actuellement
il faut s'occuper des prisonniers et au
brésil faut pas s'occuper de moi parce
que je crois que les fêtes cette
campagne qui a eu
à mener une amélioration des conditions
de détention un mois ou deux et vraiment
je pense oui ces campagnes en france oui
ces campagnes en france et ailleurs ici
même en bolivie où un mouvement de
solidarité très remarquée
les étudiants des ouvriers
et
je crois que c'est plutôt camarades
torturé du brier il faut penser moi je
vais dans une cellule du matin au soir
et du soir au matin puis c'est tout rien
à dire de plus monsieur v ce qui se
passe quand même à l'extérieur oui je
reçois les journaux bolivien la plupart
du temps en tout cas
moi je les nouvelles que les américains
veulent bien donner puisque ce sont ces
nouvelles qu'ils sont publiées par les
journaux locaux
que pensez-vous des événements qui se
sont passés en france depuis que vous
êtes sentent raisons et notamment du
départ du bébé
alors ça c'est une question vraiment
complexe que
à laquelle je ne peux pas répondre en
trois mots c'est une question très
difficile
vous pensez que c'est une chose
importante bien sûr que c'est très
important
tout ce que je souhaite
c'est que les packs avec le général de
gaulle dans la voie d'une politique
indépendante
demeure il subsiste inchangé c'est tout
ce que je souhaite pour vous le besoin
de votre libération ne semble non pas se
poser comme celui simplement de votre
individu est on sûr que non
ne serait ce que pour raison très simple
c'est que le jour où je sortirai d'ici
il faudra tous les autres pays amis
soient déjà fortes y est en effet
considéré comme un délinquant de droit
commun
et que générale en fin de droit dit
je crois pour la première fois depuis
très longtemps dans split qu'il n'y
avait pas à donner d'industeel 25
décembre tout simplement parce qu'il
avait pas de prisonniers politiques
qu'il sait bien c'est faux
mais il sait bien pourquoi il doit le
dire il doit le dire parce que la
défense très puissante à l'intérieur du
pays à l'extérieur mais il a dit qu'il
était favorable à une révision votre
procès qui serait déjà un pas vers ce
livre c'est une blague pour enfant de
trois ans
le procès n'est pas révisable il a déjà
été
confirmée en appel par le tribunal
militaire supérieur il n'y a aucune
possibilité de révision qu'en fait il a
inventé cette fausse fenêtre pour
trouver une attitude mais ce n'est pas
ni juridiquement possible ni
politiquement souhaitable quand je n'ai
aucune intention de demander la révision
de ce procès qui est un fait politique
qui doit être
considéré c'est un ange uniquement
politique c'est à dire sous l'angle de
la mystique politique dans la mesure où
c'est le moyen qui est donné aux
gouvernants des pays
dans lesquels il se produit des
changements politiques ici je crois
qu'ils aient produit un changement
politique il ya six mois
c'est un changement encore très
contradictoires très instable très
confus
et jusqu'à ce que les choses se définit
je ne sortirai pas si vous sortirez pas
tant que ce pays aura des rapports avec
l'impérialisme américain rapports qui
subsiste en profondeur et
la fraction la plus réactionnaire de
l'armée qui me maintient ici
c'est parfaitement ce qu'elle ferme
maintenant en prison puisque au prochain
coup d'état
ils auront l'occasion de régler le
problème certainement de manière plus
définitive
en sorte que ma situation est
ouverte à toutes les
toutes les surprises
vous avez dit à la fin de votre procès
je suis coupable de croire à la victoire
finale les prochaines du che est ce que
vous êtes toujours de cet avis
bien entendu pour distinguer entre une
forme maman tenait qu'a revêtu la lutte
tu te fais une inspiration est
essentielle l'inspiration
n'est pas
qui n'est pas réductible à une seule
forme de lutte inspiration d'ordre
historique ysl je crois de tous les
peuples d'amérique latine promenez-vous
n'importe où vous verrez le portrait du
che que ce soit chez les étudiants ont
scellé ce courrier le répète c'était une
erreur d'entreprendre ce qu'il a
entrepris en bolivie
non après c'est facile à dire à moi
c'est beaucoup plus difficile les
militants n'ont pas ces recours de
pouvoir se justifier ou
dénoncer les erreurs une fois qu'elles
ont été commises les militants sont des
gens qu'ils se risquent toujours un peu
et qui payent pour les risques qu'ils
prennent
oui j'ai ses camarades dont impayés
beaucoup moi je
savais
ce que je voulais dire justement c'est
que nous vous voyons là dans un cadre ma
foi assez agréable il fait beau il ya du
soleil est passé militaire tout serait
pour le mieux non mais votre cellule est
différente mais assez on m'amène jamais
ici c'est la première fois que je viens
ici plutôt la deuxième fois que je viens
ici
et comment est votre cellule belge et
elle est tout petit laid entourés de
fils de fer barbelés miradors et loin
d'ici de landreau nous sommes non
sans mettre peut-être 50 m c'est une
toute petite prison c'est une prison
comme une sorte depuis la fosse aux ours
où on sort pour les entrevues élite
depuis qu'il ya des entrevues site ou
même à fait positif vous le voyez vous
voyez traitement on en d'ordre femme qui
a maintenant une autorisation spéciale
elle a une autorisation pour rester 15
jours ici c'est vraiment formidable mais
je crois que c'est
le nom grâce et le résultat je crois que
je suis même temps non je
suis bien décidé à mais non merci
c'est le lot de chasse grâce est ce le
résultat je crois que solidarité qu'il y
ait
autant il ya six mois mais conditions
j'ai pas fait
autant il ya six mois mais comptez pas
s'il est long sont améliorées depuis
depuis deux mois vous n'avez pas
l'impression qu'avec ces améliorations
enfin surtout le la permission accordée
à votre femme et les autres
améliorations relatives vous ai parlé on
s'achemine quand même vers le nouveau
régime bolivien eux semblent vouloir
vous libérer un jour ou l'autre c'est
quand même les titres des journaux
récemment disait que le président 22
n'était pas contre une libération qu'il
fallait réviser le procès le président
au 27 ans est au centre d'un dispositif
où il ya une aile droite et une aile
gauche l'ailé gauche et révolutionnaire
évidemment ne peux pas concevoir que des
révolutions à prisonniers dans ce pays
l'ailé droite et contre révolutionnaires
et à jeter dans la balance toute la
puissance pour que je ne sorte pas d'ici
tant que cette contradiction soit par
rizzoli je ne sortirai pas
revendre on ne peut pas faire plus que
que les forces sur lesquelles ils
s'appuient
tous prend plus comment doit-elle sans
doute quelqu'un qui ait évolué depuis
il a une évolution politique
intellectuel indubitable et il cherche
l'appui du peuple
il l'a presque trouvé pas tout à fait
encore pour qu'il le trouve encore qu'il
fasse quelques quelques petits pas
est ce que vous voulez que le
gouvernement français que vos amis
français continue l'action qui sont
entreprises en votre faveur qu'il
accentue que faut-il faire parce que
parfois on a l'impression que le
gouvernement bolivien et plus les terres
est agacé on ne sait pas exactement
c'est une question délicate
le gouvernement français je me suis très
reconnaissant et tout ce qu'il a fait
mais il est évident que l'on ne peut pas
faire plus
pour beaucoup de raisons quant à mes
amis français je crois aussi plus en
fait tout ce qu'ils ont pu
je crois qu'on ne peut pas encore
définir ce qu'il faut faire
c'est en bolivie il faut se passe en
amérique du sud c'est pas en france
on a senti un peu latino américains et
et
me trouvant dans un pays latino
américains il est normal que les forces
qui m'appuient soit de 7 pays humaine
cela dit ce que les amis et ceux qui ne
sont pas des amis ces personnes que je
ne connais pas il fait en france est
vraiment émouvant pour moi remarquable
et
je crois font qu'ils en ont déjà
beaucoup fait presque trop fait et je ne
suis vraiment
pas disposés à leur en demander plus il
faudrait vraiment manqué de tout une
élémentaire modestie
c'est déjà énorme ce qui s'est passé je
crois que
je crois que c est faux il faut
poursuivi il faut
il faut me faire revenir à l'anonymat
duquel je n'aurait dû jamais sortir
je crois qu'on a beaucoup trop parlé de
la faire de vrais manière générale
j'ai un peu
c'était à considérer de dire ça parce
que ça m'arriverait finalement jeudi a
demandé ce moment difficile mais je
persiste à penser que je ne mérite pas
tous
tout ce bruit toute cette campagne
c'est quand même un homme qui est là
condamné à 30 ans de prison rollin a
tellement d'autres elle a tellement
d'autres et
mais personnellement je persiste à
penser qu'on en a beaucoup trop fait
pour voir et que vraiment je ne mérite
pas tout ça c'est noël aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous avez dépassé noël d'une
façon particulière
non
on va dire je pense lorsque vous êtes
l'amf et les jours se ressemblent rouge
où il n'y a pas de changement
si pour moi le changement c'est de vous
voir aujourd'hui il sait formule 1
c'est surprenant
je dois avouer qu'aujourd'hui on veut
noël pour moi est un jour comme un autre
sauf que ma femme est là et comme
visiter cet après midi et
tout le temps que nous vous prenons
maintenant nous l'enlevons à votre femme
oh je sais pas on peut peut-être une
compensation on donnera à 10 minutes de
plus c'est pas je remercie